[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Good evening.
Thank you all so
much for helping
us celebrate International
Women's Day at Google.
This is the first of many
Women Techmakers events
that we hope to host.
And actually this
is one of over 110
that we are
convening, or helping
to put on, in the
month of March.
So this event is one of many,
as you saw in the beginning.
We have events today that
happened in Boulder, Colorado,
in the Philippines, in
London, and New York.
And so if you look at our
hashtag Women Techmakers,
you'll see a lot of
different languages, voices,
and perspectives because of
this international community
that we're bringing
greater visibility to.
And so the Women Techmakers
program has three pillars.
And those three pillars,
I think, each one of them
we built on today.
And so of those we have
visibility, community,
and resources.
And so I think we really
increase the visibility
by seeing Pavi and Laura and
all of these great women come up
on stage and share
their stories.
We have created
community together.
I think especially during
the creative skills
for innovation course.
Which I thought was fantastic.
I love seeing all
of your prototypes.
And then resources.
We've exchanged email addresses.
And we've come up
with greater ideas
of what we can do to solve
for the particular issues
that we might see
in the industry.
And so I'm really excited
for what's to come.
And so with this, I would love
to check out our new website.
We actually launched it sometime
around 8:00 PM last night.
[LAUGHTER] g.co/WomenTechmakers.
I would love your
feedback and your ideas.
I want you to tell me
what we're missing.
I want you to tell me what I
need to add, what you love,
and if you want to be featured
on an upcoming Women Techmakers
show, If you want to
contribute to our newsletter.
I just want this to be something
that we build together.
Because Women Techmakers,
it's something for all of us.
I really feel that the
Women Techmakers program
is Google joining the
already existing movement,
standing on the shoulders of
the people that have already
laid the groundwork for
supporting women in technology.
And so this isn't just
a Google initiative,
this is an initiative
for our entire community.
And so with that,
I want to offer you
the women-techmakers at
google.com email address.
It goes directly
to me, and I will
respond to every single
email in responding
to feedback or ideas.
Again we are an open community.
And we want you to
be a part of building
the future of Women Techmakers.
So next, I want to
share a little bit
about a friend of
mine, Megan Smith, who
is about to get on stage.
Megan Smith spearheaded
Women Techmakers.
Women Techmakers
is a program that
would pop up around Google I/O.
And that's our big developer
conference that
we hold at Google.
And we sat down sometime
middle of last year
and decided that they should
be a yearlong global program.
It really shouldn't
be just something
that pops up once a year.
And so with that we've
created these pillars,
we've created these
opportunities.
And I'm really proud
of the work that Megan
is doing for women, not just
for women within Google,
but outside of Google as well.
And some of the work that
she's done within Google
is, as you'll see, she's a
VP over at Google X. She's
working on some of the
most radical moonshots
our company has ever thought of.
And with that, she
also leads Solve for X.
I encourage you to
go to solveforx.com,
where we're thinking
about, and trying
to find moonshot thinkers
that are applying breakthrough
technologies to global issues
in creating a radical solution.
She also works at
the Malala Fund.
And that's just
incredible in itself.
She's really about empowering
women inside of Google,
and great thinkers
inside of Google,
as well outside of Google.
And so with that, Megan Smith.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC  PLAYING]
MEGAN SMITH: Hello.
It's incredible be here.
It's incredible
to see all of you.
Because as we were thinking
about Women Techmakers
and imagining what it could
be, a big part of that is,
we know that there's maybe
about 16 million programmers
in the world, and we
know if we're 10 or 15%,
that means there's at least
two or 3 million of us.
I'm actually a
mechanical engineer
so I'm not a programmer,
but I can program a little.
So I'm a little bit in.
But where are we?
Why can't we see ourselves?
Why can't we be seen?
And so visibility, as Natalie
said, is the first pillar.
I want to talk today, I'm
going to jump all around,
but I really want to talk
about heroic engineering,
and a little bit about
the network and debugging
inclusion in some
interesting ways.
And so, I want to start with
what I call the ground truth.
And I want to go
to World War II.
Much of the computer
industry that we are in,
the modern computer industry,
has its roots in World War II.
Because people had
to do heroic things.
And this is a picture
from Bletchley Park.
What I love, it's a picture
of Jean Valentine, who's
a veteran code breaker
from Bletchley Park.
She also has a Googler,
who is a granddaughter,
her granddaughter is a Googler.
And so that's exciting.
But she was part of
the Bombe operators.
The ground truth for me is that
technical women have always
been in our industry.
In fact, they are
some of the founders.
And so I think
it's one of things
that we have to know, embrace,
and start making visible.
Not only Ada, who is awesome.
Walter Isaacson is working on
a book about the new digital--
the start of the digital age.
And he's been in the Bodleian
Library reading the Byron
Collection, reading Ada's paper,
the stories are totally true.
And it's a very exciting thing.
So starting with
our code crackers--
There's a story that I
got to visit Bletchley,
and I encourage you if
you're ever in London,
take the train 45 minutes out of
Paddington station and go here.
There were 10,000 people
stationed at Station X,
and more than half
of them were women.
And they cracked
the Enigma codes.
And people credit this tech team
with saving 11 million lives
and shortening the
war by two years.
One of my favorite stories, I
came into the main house there,
and I met this woman,
this older woman
who is now retired
and volunteers there.
And she said, she was five
years old at Bletchley
during the war.
And she and her twin
sister, her little brother,
and older brother
lived in the stables.
And they were in this one
section stables next door
to Dilly Knox's team.
And Dilly Knox was one of
the astonishing mathematical
leaders of Bletchley.
And he led a team of
women mathematicians.
And she said to me, her
mom used to always say,
"Shhh, the girls are working,
shhh, the girls are working."
I want that to be
Hollywood movie.
And I want to know about
those girls who were working,
and who saved all those lives,
and started our industry.
The second image that I want
to show you is Charles Vest.
This is president Chuck Vest.
Sadly, we lost him in December.
He was the 15th
president of MIT.
And I am on the MIT board.
I was at a meeting yesterday
and the day before,
and we had a celebration
of his life at MIT.
One of things that I knew about,
but it was sort of vague to me,
and I wanted to bring it back
because it was just brought up.
There was a moment
when the MIT faculty
women did an incredible
watershed story.
They took it upon themselves to
look at lab space and science
and all the unfairness that
was going on on campus.
And to Chuck's credit,
when they came to him
with the results of the
study-- actually in process,
he kept encouraging
them to do more.
And then once they
came with the data,
he added a quote to the
front of that paper that
was really impactful in science.
And he said, "I
have always believed
that contemporary
gender discrimination
within universities is part
reality, and part perception."
Vest wrote in a much cited
preface to the MIT report
on gender equity.
"But I now understand
that reality is by far
the greater part
of the balance."
And it was so incredibly
said that they got so
many phone calls, outreach
from across the world.
Everybody wanted
to act on this data
and follow that leadership.
So thinking about the ground
truth of measuring problems
and getting the
word out about them
is one of the
fundamental things we
can do in the spirit of
Chuck and those women who
did that work.
And then this slide
is from this morning.
I started the morning with,
actually with Little League,
opening day with our boys.
And then I came over to
this mentorship walk,
run by Vital Voices.
Do people know Vital Voices?
Yes, no, a little bit?
It was started by
Hillary Clinton
as a gathering, just a
little after Beijing.
But really to start to highlight
these astonishing women
out there who are doing amazing
work in their communities.
I think of these
guys almost as CAA
for incredible entrepreneurial
women around the world.
And they find these rock
stars and they help them,
almost like angel or
venture investing into them.
And Elise was onstage, and she
said something interesting.
She said it's
International Women's Day,
and yes, we need help
from the world for women.
But really, it's not that women
need the world to help us,
it's that the world needs women.
They need us to step up and do
the amazing things we already
do and do them even more.
And I want to flip
into heroic engineering
now, because that's
what we all do.
So this is a really cool slide.
It's an image of one of
our engineers hooked up
to data centers
to Google traffic.
And some people may
have seen this before.
But basically, the dots
represent certain amounts
of search traffic.
And the red is English, you
see some Spanish in the lighter
green, yellow, and then the
darker green, the Portuguese,
a little French over here, blue.
But basically to me what
this imagery represents,
it happens to be Google
traffic, but it's really
about the internet.
We are wired as a
planet in a way that's
really different from the past.
And so that presents
extraordinary opportunity.
And Clinton always says
21st Century is really
the age of creative
collaboration.
And look at what's going on.
And just to kind of touch
on the feeling of that,
we had the Google Science
Fair students actually
here in this room, the 15
winners from around the world.
And I was a science fair kid.
I don't know if we have other
science fair people out there,
yes.
I went to the library and I got
these books on solar energy.
And I looked at them, and
I did my project that way.
These guys are on the web.
And they do breakthrough work.
I mean, we did great work.
They do breakthrough work.
They are advancing the field.
The 13, 14, 15, 16, 17 year
olds, advancing the field,
connecting, because they can
do science at that level.
It's a whole other
magnitude for science fair.
Thinking about the
computer scientists,
you guys are the most
wired people in the world.
These are computer
science graduates
at the University of
Herat in Afghanistan,
80 miles from the Iran border.
They are wired.
They are starting companies.
This is their start-up center.
This is happening across the
planet, and it's exciting.
Just thinking about how
data and point of view
has become adjacent.
Of course there is
Wikipedia, which I love.
This is a tool called Map
Maker that Lali put together
in Bangalore with a team.
Most of the world doesn't
have metadata for mapping.
And it's been a challenge
for our geo teams
and open street map and others.
This is Lahore, Pakistan,
a couple years ago.
You would go on the map and
look at emerging countries,
and there would be one line.
And you'd know there was
a million people there.
So this is leveraging the
diaspora and adjacency,
and the adjacency of
data and knowledge,
to have the people of Lahore
draw themselves on to the map.
And so this is what we're seeing
out of crowd-sourced data.
And in fact, astonishing
activity on this tool.
Mapping is so important
because it helps with commerce,
it helps with
ambulance deliveries,
it helps with city planning.
We need this data.
People help themselves.
And data that was
adjacent comes together.
Sal Khan, people know
Sal, the Khan Academy.
This is a really
old screen shot,
but I love it because
the density of it,
it's so incredible.
This one guy teaching
all these classes.
And it's not to say that
one person should really
teach all classes, but it's this
moment of somebody stepping up
in a heroic way and saying,
we need to change education.
I have an idea.
Let me just start.
And it shows the
cracks in the dam,
and the beginning of
the change of education.
These are CS for High School,
awesome computer science high
school teachers who
are now collaborating.
We flash mobbed them together
into a physical weekend
a couple of years ago.
Now hundreds of them are
collaborating on the web
to fix the curriculum.
Master teachers are
going to fix the schools,
not people sort of
putting down teachers.
FIRST Robotics, do we have
FIRST Robotics people?
Yes, no, yes.
Nationals, shouldn't school
feel like "Friday Night Lights"?
This is the nationals
in Saint Louis.
This is in our son's third grade
school classroom, very hands
on.
And what I love with this idea
that education could really
teach children that in
effort, there's joy.
And we're doing
in Malala, we talk
a lot about what does it mean
to have a quality education?
Is it just like this content?
Because we know that a
lot of very smart people
have done some pretty awful
stuff, some very educated
people.
So what does it mean to
have ethics and effort
and be included and be
in the 21st century?
So thinking about the web that
way, and how we work together.
This is that an
experiment in Ethiopia
where people have tablets.
And they've gone
to a village where
no one can read within 10 miles.
And the experiment is could
the kids teach themselves
if they have the same apps
that we're giving our kids.
Could they just start
collaborating and do that?
And in fact, in the first
week they used 50 apps.
And they're so close to reading.
It's incredibly exciting.
And I put them near last
year's science fair winners
because the two guys
there are from Swaziland.
And I think very soon these kids
will be these kids if we just
get them the content
and get them each other
and get them the master
teachers network.
Network data to get us out of
climate change information, not
only the engineering
we need to do,
but the information technology
work that we need to do.
This is Earth Engine.
I've got to work at the
beginning of Book Search.
And I would have never
thought of this application.
You know we're
scanning all the books,
working with the publishers,
with the libraries,
and engaging that way.
This is a tool,
the New York Times
published this particular data.
But all the words that were
ever written are now adjacent.
And that's a data set
that's very interesting
to traverse across.
This is someone doing an
analysis that the New York
Times published
on the word women.
The word women is not used
very much in books in English
from 1800 to 2008 until the
modern women's rights movement
started.
What can we learn
about ourselves
by reflecting the data
back to ourselves?
So this is the
network I showed you.
But when the globe
spins around, there's
still many places where
the network is not.
This is a serious problem.
Lots of talent is not included.
900 million people in Africa are
not in the global conversation.
It was so excited to
see the Oscars because
in the main shots every time
when Ellen was like running
around with pizza,
you were seeing
people who are from
Africa, finally in the mix,
finally collaborating with us.
That's awesome.
The truth is that as of
2005, this is actually
the network map
for this continent.
There was no cable.
That lightweight
pink means planned.
No cable next to a continent.
I'm not sure what the
World Bank was doing.
And then over here it's missing
a whole bunch of countries.
So this is a super huge failing
of the development world
and the people doing that work.
The good news is it
looks like this now.
And I think one of
the greatest changes
we will see in the world is
as our colleagues from Africa
join us.
And so this is an
image of iHub Nairobi.
You could be South of Market,
you could be in Silicon Alley.
David Sengeh is a
Ph.D. student at MIT
wrote a great blog
about aid to Africa
becomes made in Africa, the fab
lab movement alive and well.
This is what the actual network
is looking like right now
globally, so a lot of
gray we've got to fill in.
We are doing crazy projects
at Google X like Project Loon,
using balloons as
an intermediary
to try to get the web to places.
We have this idea of moonshots.
So moonshot being, like
the original moonshot,
what's a huge problem or
opportunity in the world?
Is there some technology that
sounds like science fiction
but we could bring it to bear
on some kind of radical solution
for solving that problem.
There have been
moon shot pioneers.
We're doing it at
X, but I wanted
to call out one of
my favorites, which
is George Washington Carver.
When he went from Missouri,
when he was invited by Booker T.
Washington to go to Tuskegee in
Alabama and join the faculty.
He saw the problem of the
monocrop culture of the US
and the malnutrition
and the problems
that we had of not understanding
crop rotation and the future
of how agriculture had to be.
And he went into the lab
as a heroic scientist,
as a heroic engineer.
And he worked through
all kinds of ideas
for sweet potatoes and peanuts.
And the stories went on.
And then he figured out
how to radically get it
out there using Jesup Wagons.
And he changed our country.
So Google X, just a
quick touch on it,
people think we
have a lot of hype.
But the truth is it's really
a skunkworks kind of place,
really messy, really fun.
The slight difference between
maybe other parts of Google
is that we are a
lot of hardware.
That's where the
big difference is.
We're looking for people who are
optics engineers in robotics,
and bio and these
other disciplines
that Google hasn't
classically had.
Desks look like this.
Our goal is to do
these moonshots.
And culture, we want to
feel like Willy Wonka.
It's got to be fun, interesting,
collaborative, unusual.
Isabella who, we
were doing a video,
and she's the designer of Glass.
She's like, well, I didn't
feel odd coming to Google X
because kind of everybody's odd.
I thought, that's good.
But this idea of
Peter and Petra Pans
surrounded by awesome teams.
So, Solve for X is the thing
that I'm actually personally
most passionate about
at X. Which is, could we
make a platform to help
all these amazing moonshot
pioneers out in the
world be more visible.
We often celebrate what people
finished in our science history
books.
We celebrate the success.
But could we help people
who are in process?
Elon Musk, 2008, when everyone
thought he was insane.
Why is he buying that factory?
His rockets are blowing up.
And look at Space X
now, look at Tesla now.
So how can we celebrate people
when they are in process?
And the other
thing I do a lot of
is, we make sure that people
from all different continents,
people of different races,
men and women, people
of different age groups, are
really celebrated on the site.
So people can see, you
can't be what you can't see.
So I'm going to flip it
to this last part which
is about debugging inclusion.
And so networks are
incredible places
to do our heroic engineering,
to change commerce, et cetera.
I'm from Buffalo so in addition
to the Silk Road, which
is such an incredible
example of a network that
changed the world, I
added the Erie Canal.
The Erie Canal is interesting
for the US development
because it dropped the grain
price by a factor of 10
to get goods in and
out of the country.
It really changed the game
from a commerce perspective.
But it also is the
place where most
of the major abolition
and suffrage conversations
happened.
In fact, Seneca Falls is right
here with one of the locks.
And how many people know about
the Declaration of Sentiments?
Yeah, it's so interesting to me.
So the Declaration of Sentiments
is the watershed document
around women's rights.
It's the first women's
rights convention.
I can't believe, in
and around visibility,
that it's not taught
in all of our schools,
in elementary school.
But Elizabeth Cady Stanton
wrote this document.
You should read it.
It has 15 sentiments.
Many of them are true
in some countries still.
It's the watershed moment
for us in the beginning
of women's rights.
I feel like we're making
huge progress, right?
We stand on the
shoulders of giants
from Elizabeth, to people
like Kathrine Switzer, who
had her numbers stripped
off in the Boston Marathon.
A moment of extreme
violence in the,
Boston Marathon from the '70s.
The guy didn't want
her in the race.
But she finished that race.
And I would encourage you to
watch the Makers videos which
have her story and others.
We did Makers at Google
videos, by the way,
of Pavni and others, if you want
to see some of their stories.
But really getting
the stories told,
the work that Sheryl's
doing, the work
that is happening at the UN.
I feel like we're
making progress.
But in tech, we still have
to work on our visibility.
I did a panel session
on STEAM and STEM
at the Makers Conference.
And Mae Jemison, the first
African American woman
in space, said, technical
women have an issue,
because we're a
minority in tech.
And we're often unseen.
And women have been
kind of convinced
not to follow math and science.
They are sometimes afraid of it.
And so we're a
minority amongst women.
And they sometimes
don't include us.
And so we're totally invisible.
And so I think that we,
the technical women,
need to show up.
And we need to
have conversations
with our colleagues.
So they're not afraid
of what we're doing.
And include them, and get them
excited about we're doing.
Because it's really
a way that we're
going to solve a
lot of problems.
I won't go into all
the details here.
But you see the
Bletchley Park folks.
The Eniac, which is the first US
digital computer, World War II,
University of Pennsylvania,
first programmers were women.
Their stories haven't been
told, of course Grace Hopper.
katherine Johnson, African
American woman now 96,
calculated the trajectories
for Alan Shepard, John Glenn,
and the Apollo mission.
We need to know about her.
She's awesome.
Her job was to be a computer.
She wrote 26 papers.
She was [INAUDIBLE]
author 26 papers at NASA.
Her name is only on one.
Hedy Lamarr, et cetera,
the Apollo women.
Who saw the movie "Jobs"?
Do you remember the
Macintosh scene?
So Steve, Ashton-- he did a
good job I thought-- walks in,
and there's these guys hanging
out in this skunk works project
called the Mac.
Burrell Smith is kind of
asleep on a desk and wakes up.
Burrell is the guy
on the far side here,
he's got the keyboard here.
Bill Atkinson is in
the middle, starts
engaging the actor
of Jobs, Ashton.
He has the Mac shirt here.
He is in the middle there.
Some of the other guys on
this side are in the scene.
Andy Hertzfeld actually works
at Google now, he's amazing.
I worked with him
at General Magic.
There's a scene where
Steve Jobs goes and finds
this engineer who
is a rock star.
He is coding.
He has a conversation.
Andy said he will join
the Mac in two days.
Steve says OK.
And then unplugs his computer,
picks up the computer
and brings it to the team
in that moment, true story.
Andy is there.
Are there some
people on this screen
that are not in the movie?
This is the "Rolling
Stone" historic photos
of the original Mac
team, documenting
the team that created the Mac.
Who is missing?
AUDIENCE: The women.
MEGAN SMITH: All of them.
So in this picture there's seven
men, four women, and a baby.
This is Joanna Hoffman.
She graduated in
physics from MIT.
And she was the product
manager of the Macs.
Steve's right hand person.
Kind of like Salar or
Susan for us, like amazing.
Susan Kare.
What was so cool about the
Mac was its graphics, right.
And so, Bill Atkinson
wrote the back end.
Susan did the front end.
Everything you saw was Susan.
Why did Hollywood
write them out?
I don't know.
But the good news is we're
working on this stuff.
The documentary about the Eniac
programmers is just completed.
It's going to go through
the film festival circuit.
It's awesome.
And the stories are true.
A wonderful ICANN lawyer
interviewed four of the six
of them before they died.
So we have that record.
So we can resurrect
that lost history.
And then in terms of
Geena Davis and Hollywood,
Geena has been measuring
the lack of women and girls
in children's television.
And the lack of women, like
80% of the jobs in children's
television held by
male characters.
And so we're starting
to use CS to help
make her tools more real time.
So lots of good stuff there.
The founding of
Women Techmakers,
which we invite all of you to
become collaborators on this.
It's really about visibility
and community and resources.
We started with Google
I/O because it's
the place where we reach
out to the most developers.
That was our strategy there.
We're doing a lot of stuff
around trying to debug this.
We don't know the answers
how to fix these problems.
We've inherited the
weight of history.
None of us created
the bias that exists
in the world for
women and minorities.
But we can work to fix it.
One of them is doing unconscious
bias training on all of Google.
It's really helping us.
I think the biggest
breakthrough is
in the Doodle Team,
which was receptive.
But we really, as a company,
would have never meant to
not celebrate a woman's
birthday in the doodles.
And we did that for seven years.
We never celebrated
a woman's birthday.
And then we realized,
people pointed out,
and we started to dig.
History is biased.
We only do doodles about
people who are not alive.
So we weren't finding
them and celebrating them.
So they started to
get to 20 to 30%.
This year after doing
bias training, and the way
the world has changed, as of
January 1, they are at 50/50.
And you could see it.
It's changing.
So I'll end with two slides.
First, this one.
Which is remember,
the girls are working.
And they always have been.
And they always will be.
And then I think
one of the secrets
is, I was really lucky to get
taught acoustics by Professor
Bose, who we lost last year.
And one of the things that
he would do as a professor,
he would also give us advice.
And one of the greatest
pieces of advice
he gave us was, you guys
are high performing people,
you are doing your stuff.
But figure out what
you love to do.
What are you passionate about?
And do that.
Because you will be
unstoppable, if you do that.
And so I just encourage you.
The diversity of all
of the millions of us,
the technical women, the
computer science women,
is broad.
This industry and this
planet needs us badly.
So bring what you want to do,
and what you want to discover,
what you want to make.
Raise your voice,
raise your visibility,
and find your X. And find
your team, and let's network
and make it happen.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MEGAN SMITH: So these
guys said that we
were going to do one
or two questions.
And then, [INAUDIBLE]
do you want to do that?
Anybody have any questions?
AUDIENCE: Can I say thank you.
That was awesome
and so inspiring.
And really made
this day worth it.
MEGAN SMITH: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Along those lines.
One of my strategies,
when Natalie and we all
were brainstorming
about Women Techmakers,
was, "We Are the Ones
We've Been Waiting For"
is that Alice Walker book.
And just own it.
And sometimes I
call it, bring it.
Instead of yet another
panel about why there's not
enough women and minorities
in tech, it is so boring.
Right?
And it doesn't engage anyone.
It doesn't capture
their imagination.
And so instead, if they can see
you, and what you are doing,
it will change the
way they think.
And then we can also
add in the problem
and start to debug
them and work on them.
But bring it.
And so as we do
this stuff, that's
one of my thoughts on that.
Any other quick questions?
It's been a long day.
There's one over here.
AUDIENCE: How do you
see the challenges
that women face in tech as
unique from the challenges
women might face
in other industries
where they are also minorities,
or we are also minorities?
MEGAN SMITH: I think it's a
challenge and an opportunity.
Everybody is facing unconscious
bias, the guys and we,
the women, none of us
created it, as I said.
The Doodle Team is
such a good example.
Because Ryan and the team
would have never done-- just
wouldn't have done it.
But when they wake
up, it changes things.
So I think you have
to bring the data.
Because I really think
our industry doesn't think
we have a problem.
We are such a data
driven industry
that we think we're
such a meritocracy.
And we are in a lot of ways.
It's one of the greatest
things about tech.
In fact, I ran an internet
company called Plan It Out
in the gay community.
And Tom Riley, who
founded Plan It Out.
There was a guy named
Michelangelo Signorile,
and he was talking about the
gay community in the closet.
And he wrote a book
about media industry
in New York and the
intense closet there.
This was sort of in the '80s
and '90s and as the AIDS crisis
was happening.
The intense closet of
the government and DC,
and the intense closet and the
oppression in Hollywood in LA.
And he added a chapter
called the Silicon Solution.
And it was really about how
we are a meritocracy in tech
and how we think that way.
So I do think that we actually
have the greatest opportunity
because of that to
change the fastest.
But I think there
are two issues.
We notice one issue
in our company.
People really aren't convinced
that we have a problem.
And so they need
to understand that.
They need the Chuck
Vests and other people.
Larry gave us a
company wide OKR to try
to become the best company
for women and minorities.
So now everybody has to think
about what does that mean?
What do I need to do?
It opens innovation space.
Get people convinced, use
data, use whatever it takes.
People outsource it
to the diversity team.
Every company has
a diversity team,
who are incredible people.
But how many of them are there?
Maybe 30 maximum at any company.
And so you can't
outsource it to them.
You have to use them.
You have to do it
yourself, as a manager,
and use them as
your awesome experts
to help you do it better.
And so we need to get the
companies to start doing that.
We need to have those
conversations with the HR folks
and really get innovative.
We do not know how to
solve this problem.
So we should recognize that
and go at it as an industry.
And really back
the way Elon Musk
thinks which is what's the
fundamental physics for doing
this.
So it could be possible.
And so what is the fundamental
fix, the physics, the data,
that is preventing us.
What's this very complex stuff?
So that's, I think how,
the overarching strategy
of how we should approach it.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I also want to say thank
you so, so, so much.
And I brought my
daughter here today.
She's 12.
And we live in
Emeryville, Oakland border
and the statistics
and experiences
for black and brown
girls in Oakland,
South Africa, Los Angeles,
New York, are pretty terrible.
And so I wanted to know if
you had one piece of advice
that you would get to a black
an brown girls about getting
into tech, and using tech
as a tool for liberation,
empowerment.
What would you say
to them, or her?
MEGAN SMITH: Yeah
so a couple things.
One of things that I want you
to know is about the women
that I was talking about, like
Katherine Johnson, the women
who calculated the
trajectories for the Apollo
missions and stuff.
That African American
women have been
part of fundamental
inventions for the whole time.
But for some weird
reason, people
have written them out of
history, or down in history.
So let's bring that back.
So that the kids can see that.
That's important for the
boys and the girls to see.
It's important for
everybody to see.
She has one of the 300 flags
from the Apollo mission.
She is in the elite Apollo team.
We need to know
that she was there.
Same thing actually,
just in general.
It's this sort of
weight of history,
let's bring the true history
forward and know it and own it.
Even if they weren't the
majority of the team,
they are in the team,
and they are contributing
at elite levels,
sometimes founders.
I think the second
thing is that, we've
been doing some studies
about women, and just kids
getting into tech.
And one of the key
ones is encouragement.
So just being here
is going to help you.
It's going to help people.
All of you, anything you can do.
It turns out that
encouragement doesn't
have to come from a technical
person, it just has to come.
One of the sad statistics
that we've come across with
and we're working on is
that 70% of the computer
science high school teachers
think that the boys are better
than the girls, despite
overwhelming evidence.
And so you know the
stereotypes that they've had,
and the boring way that
we teach are playing out,
that the programmer video
game kids are getting through
and the other kids who wouldn't.
And Harvey Mudd has
done an astonishing job
of changing their curriculum
in order to attract everybody.
And they are at
50:50 men and women.
They have a lot more minorities.
Have a lot more people.
They have grown the field.
Because they changed it to
creative problem solving.
Who doesn't want to be
creative and solve problems?
And they don't walk in and
start with math, they walk in
and they start with
problems and impact.
Because it turned out
that a whole set of people
just want to change the world.
And they don't love
science and math
because it hasn't been taught
in a way that is accessible.
So they do things
like go to Congress.
They do things like
start nonprofits.
They do amazing things.
But they don't include tech.
And so those are some of the
weakest tech areas, sectors.
Look at what happened
with the health website.
Look at what happens in
development and NGOs.
They're not technical because
people are afraid of technology
because we taught it wrong.
So I think wherever you
can, touch the field.
Do science fair so you see
that science and the history
in the way they're teaching
but it's actually doing it.
It's what we do.
That's awesome.
The other break through that
the University of Maryland has,
which is-- Actually
the university
that we find the most
African American software
engineers for Google
is how fast can you
have a student be in the field.
Because they have
so many stereotypes.
I mean you watch "The
Big Bang Theory,"
do you really want to
work with those people?
Probably not.
And so they think it's
not they get it is.
And people think it's lonely.
And they think it's solitary.
And it's not in any way.
And so we need to kind of
have Hollywood help us.
And get the information
through and get the kids
to our field to do those things.
So there are a couple
things I'd recommend.
So we want to get you
guys to reception.
A small group of
us had this idea.
And it's so exciting to see what
Natalie and Kyle and everybody
have done to take it to level.
And we want to give it to
you guys, women techmakers.
And, you know,
let's go bring it.
So thank you for being here.